so what do the results of the U.S
midterms mean for the rest of the world
here to discuss this is DW's Chief
International editor Richard Walker
Richard let's start with the war in
Ukraine that's obviously on everyone's
Minds here in Europe uh the U.S is one
of the biggest supporters of the
government in Ukraine both financially
and militarily
um will that change if Republicans gain
control of the house yeah I mean
definitely a bit a big question on on
many people's minds in Ukraine but also
here in Europe and and it's true Terry I
mean just to give you a sense of the
scale of the support that's come from
the United States uh for the ukrainians
40 plus billion dollars of of support
has been pouring in during the course of
this year
um Joe Biden had to go to Congress to
get that money approved that money is
pretty much spent now so what's going to
happen next and this has been really
kind of bursting out into the Limelight
because the Republican Party who now it
looks very much like are going to
control at least the House of
Representatives there's a division in
the party about what to do about Ukraine
um you know the Republicans
traditionally especially since Reagan
you know the party of kind of Defense
Hawks you know that you know party that
you would expect to want to stand up to
Russia but of course Donald Trump had an
unusual relationship with Vladimir Putin
and the kind of trumpian wing of the
party has been saying things that are
causing a lot of jangling nerves in
Ukraine for instance Marjorie Taylor
green I think she's well known as kind
of a trumpier than Trump in the in the
House of Representatives she said just
recently if the Republicans take over
there won't be there'll be not another
penny for Ukraine JD Vance who's coming
into the senate in Ohio he said he
doesn't really care what happens in
Ukraine so this has caused a lot of
concern now uh Kevin McCarthy he's going
to be the the guy who's probably going
to be the the speaker of the house now
the new system he also said that there
will be no blank check for Ukraine going
forward now he's since been trying to
sort of tone that down a little bit but
I think at the very least Republican
politics is going to become a factor in
this equation for the United States for
the US Administration in thinking about
how to uh continue funding of the
ukrainians that these Vision to the
Republican party and how they play out
how it plays out with Donald Trump you
know coming up to the primaries you know
next year if he's going to throw in his
hat into the ring to to try to become
president that's going to become a
factor that will at the very least
complicate matters
now all of these statements that you
just referenced there about politicians
particularly in the Republican Party
they're being listened to very carefully
in in Moscow right and so let's get an
idea of what the Kremlin is making of
this I've just got a statement here
coming from the Kremlin today Kremlin
spokesman Dmitry peskov saying these
elections cannot change anything
essential relations are still are and
will remain bad
so uh Richard no no change anticipated
in uh in russian-american relations I
mean to an extent he's right and it's an
understatement relations between the US
and Russia are worse than are extremely
bad at the moment
of course yeah I mean if you kind of go
through like the the people we were just
talking about of course you know it it
would be quite pretty nice for Russia if
you know people like Marjorie Taylor
green people like JD Vance so these
people who've said things which could be
interpreted as rather more rather
unsympathetic to Ukraine potentially
sympathetic to the Russian side of the
in this conflict
um that that would of course play to
Russia's favor so the fact that what
we're looking at here does not appear to
be you know a sort of a republican wave
that the Trump wing of the Republican
party is if anything weakened coming out
of this that many of the the candidates
that Trump endorse did not do so well
um that that I think that will probably
be causing a bit of disappointment in
Russia because you know what plays best
from the Russian point of view is a
divided United States and the United
States still looks extremely divided but
it's not perhaps quite as as
catastrophic a level of division as we
might have anticipated going into today
okay so the Russians are watching this
uh the Chinese as well of course it's
that's America's other big foreign
policy headache as it were
Republicans have slightly I don't know
do they are they still on the same page
with the Democrats when it comes to
policy towards China or can we
anticipate some changes with the uh with
the U.S attitude towards China yeah well
well so far you know China has is is a
bit of a different case from the from
Russia in American politics and it's
often said that you know being tough on
China is pretty much the only thing
where you can get really bipartisan
agreements at the moment
um that both parties are pretty much
settled on a policy that's very
antagonistic towards China this partly
dates back to to Donald Trump who of
course have opened this trade war
against China he really kind of like
took on
the Chinese very aggressively after
initially trying to reach out to Xi
Jinping the Chinese president
um but Biden has really picked that up
and almost run even further with it with
with a series of measures which are
really uh you know take taking the
confrontation to China pretty seriously
so if anything this um this new Congress
if anything is more likely to see the
two sides trying to outbid each other in
terms of toughness on China rather than
in the case of Russia where there were
some concerns that it might water U.S
policy down Richard thank you so much uh
Chief International editor Richard
Walker